listen tonight Ryan Ryan used to be the
access rep at the college so he
basically officially did what I did
unofficially on YouTube yeah yeah I was
doing yeah I was doing I did things like
school outreach work and school sort of
things like looking at doing the YouTube
channel and sort of going down the path
which Simon had already tried that that
make sense more official and hopefully
more useful way but definitely I was
popular cause Simon now but what I'm
doing is I'm going to sit down and
interview Ryan about the access work
which Oxford does since the peers does I
thought you guys might wanna listen in
okay so let me talk about broadening
access and outreach what we're basically
saying is that the university has a
commitment that anyone can come here who
is good enough to study here regardless
of background or financial means so what
so you do get slightly varying
definitions what particularly accesses
and what out which is what school
liaison work is but what really the
collective endeavor across the
universities and colleges is trying to
do is to try and reach out and basically
grab lots of talented people who should
come and study here from where they
might be
now obviously across United Kingdom
they're a huge educational disadvantages
along Geographic socio-economic lines
now obviously there's very little that
the university can do about that but
what it can do is mainly tackle things
like perception so the point
specifically about outreach work is
saying that if you are good enough to
come here and you want to commit come
here we don't want you to be put off for
the wrong reasons so there might be a
range of good reasons for example why
you might not want to go to Oxford you
might not feel the course is right for
you the department's quite right you may
not like the quite intensive tutorial
system you may prefer to work in you
know seminars and things all that even
though box it does do a bit of that as
well
so the range of perfect good reasons why
you might look at Oxford and say no I'd
like to study elsewhere but the point is
with this outreach work is that we want
you to make the best decision possible
and to be informed about it so the main
thing that outreach work is concerned to
do is to just give people more
information
and particularly to give more
information to people from sort
backgrounds which haven't usually in the
past applied to Oxford
so that might include particular
geographical region say like the north
or Wales or places like that obviously a
great majority of applicants come from
the southeast and that sort of area so
it's partly on that sort of geographical
lines and obviously to do with the state
versus private divide you know we want
to make sure that and it's good
obviously it's in the university's own
interest that it has the best people for
well from whatever background coming to
study here and contributing to the
universe these academic success on that
sort of lioness or perceptions which it
might be dealing with are things like I
don't think Oxford's for me because I
don't thought I could fit in I
particularly I don't think I'm the sort
of person who usually goes to Oxford
therefore would I enjoy it also to do
with things particularly along Student
Finance issues the great thing which I
found doing out outreach worker sir is
the ability to go up to people and say
the university has the most
comprehensive and generous financial
package available out of any university
for undergraduate so with all the
changes in the P system aside there is
no reason why anyone should ever be put
off coming here as an undergraduate
because the financial reasons in fact
the university has a specific obligation
if you like where it says that you
should never have to leave Oxford as an
undergraduate because of financial need
there are a range of sources things like
the access to learning fund in the past
it might be might be renamed now lots of
student hardship funds across big
University and College that mean that if
you're struggling during your time here
as you know once you've arrived because
of financial issues that should never be
a reason for you leaving which is up to
be brilliant it's about giving
information along those lines and also
of course about demystifying the
application process and saying that
actually whatever you might read about
about Oxford in the media or whatever a
popular perception you might have about
it the tutors here are concerned with
their subject it's what they teach and
research all their life they want the
best people for their subject to come
here for them to teach and the
admissions process is all about that and
not anything
my sort of experience with outreach from
Oxford first began when I was in
secondary school I went to a
comprehensive school in reading and in
my sixth form when I was in sixth form I
applied for a summer school which was
then run by the Sutton trust chatter
concerned with education with
disadvantage which is but it's now won
by the university itself when it's now
called unique and I'd recommend anyone
to apply for it and it's absolutely
brilliant and what that did was it it
was a residential so for five to six
days load of students came from across
the UK and they were all from
backgrounds which don't usually apply to
Oxford but also incredibly academically
able sometimes fighting lycée and what
we did over the five days was just we
had an experience what Oxford was like
so the main thing of course was the
academic program so we did things like
we went to lectures we had seminars and
classes and for the history strand which
was where I was on over the week we did
a load of reading in the library and
then we worked an essay and then we had
a discussion about it just as you would
do in any normal week as an
undergraduate here and it still remains
one of the happiest and the best when
the best weeks of my life because it was
so much fun it's amazing how you get to
get a collection of students from across
the UK all sorts of different
backgrounds and you get them together
for five days around the subject they
like and you have an amazing time and
you make a load offense some of the
thing I want to do in contact with and
more importantly because you you're in
Oxford the whole time you're talking to
tutors you live and eat in the college's
and you do other activities as well
actually quick tivities they might say
shape of being at university so for
example we had a pop on the final night
which is a fancy dress party which is
really really fun we went to formal
halls and see what they were like and we
did things like so you know went to
cinema and we did sports and stuff like
that a couple years ago and I was
working on it we did the salsa dancing
which is interesting but difficult
anyway so I so I went on that a couple
years ago and since then I've been
working on it myself as an academic
mentor and I still think actually in
terms of everything the university does
that's one of the most interesting
things to work on and also it's one of
the most effective
because it is absolutely amazing cute
these students turn up at the weekend
and they may have all sorts of different
perceptions about awards it is like and
the important thing is is they spend a
week chatting not just a tutors but to
normal Oxford students for five days and
that does a great deal to dispel any
sort of myths they might have about it
now I won't make the bold claim the
Oxford students are normal but they do
they that you get a sense that you know
the main reason why people are here is
because they really like their subject
and they really like doing it and that's
the most important thing and that's
what's absolutely brilliant about being
here for five days is it meant I could
go back to say for example other people
my year who might have been thinking of
applying and say look they're really not
like what you know the newspapers might
say or you know it's not Whitehead
revisited basically and that was
absolutely brilliant and say in a broad
sense that is one of most effective
things that University does but that's
sort of almost one most of the more
intensive end of sort of the activities
they do so most of it is concerned with
sort of less intensive work like open
days study days and visit school visit
by schools to Oxford do a great deal of
work on social media things like YouTube
obviously and then obviously things like
Twitter and stuff like that and all of
it is sort of aims to get past these
perceptions and say what is it actually
like for the vast majority of students
studying Oxford what are their daily
lives like and is this somewhere where
you would you know like to come
basically so as I say yeah we do a lot
more things sort of around open days and
study days it's usually wet and
graduated a long different year group so
I think morally speaking we usually
start most work from year ten onwards so
that sort of stage its to live sort of
investigating options like what sort of
things do you have to think a little bit
about now so that you leave options open
in the future things like you know what
Jesus seized you are you thinking of
doing what is levels and stuff like that
just so that people have a sort of
general I do
and then obviously as you get sort of
through year to year 12 obviously then
you're much more concerned with things
like how to actually apply to University
you know what went to use like more the
admission tests like and again
demystifying that whole experience and
saying actually this puppy isn't as
terrified
you think and even if it is slightly
terrifying it's terrifying because the
university wants to have a regular
system so that they know that you know
you're the right person to come here and
that once you arrive you're going to be
able to cope with the workload which is
obviously quite considerable well
obviously the university does a great
deal of work monitoring the results of
is a bout which works it's one of the
ways actually in which they can see that
things like the UNIX Eminescu our most
successful because they can see you know
how many of these students go on to
apply and how many get in so they can
and the unique some schools are at
particular success of the University in
that regard
obviously they're the one the most
intensive and most costly because the
whole summer school is free for anyone
who comes on it it's under most
intensive things they do that it's also
the most effective yeah as I say the
university is a range of data which it
can use to assess its impact that said I
don't want to go into this in too much
detail the university is in some of its
outreach work acting against fast
socio-economic fault lines if you like
they've been in British society for a
very very long time
things like inequalities around
educational advantage and opportunity
which Werner's are said a bit before
along geographical economic social and
obviously these lines of perception
there's a great deal of work and
particularly with you know recent faint
changes in the fee structures like
confusions you get there there's a great
deal against which university has to
operate that said the university is
committed to it and it learns from doing
this over the last couple years what is
you know what it's working to be most
effective at the university can really
work wonders I don't think in this
regard but it can do whatever it can and
they can try and see gradually what is
most successful and I think it does
extremely good job of doing that
one of the best things about I think the
way Oxford does it is that the
university operates over you know an
umbrella network and it does all its own
sort of stuff but also you have
individual colleges who are all working
along these similar aspirations to do a
widening and participation and
and outreach work and obviously that can
also again the nice element about
college competitiveness comes in there
and on that note Saint Peter's last year
I think did it was reading in the
newspaper the other day did more
outreach events than any other but what
I think is most successful why think
could be improved I think the university
is absolutely going in the right
direction in getting students front and
foremost in terms of its outreach work
obviously tutors outreach members of
staff have a huge important role to play
there the linchpins in a sort of
widening access initiative but I think
it's so much more believable to have the
students in front of you that's one of
the reasons why I think the summer
school is so successful because you
you're hanging around with Oxford
students for five days and you can talk
to them about you know anything you know
what what what the Cubs clubs and pubs
like you know what should work like you
get to know them very very quickly and
quite intensively and you very quickly
realize that the stereotypes which all
these perceptions you might have about
looks would very very quickly break down
so I think having students punt and for
most of any outreach initiative is is
absolutely the best thing like the ox or
project Simon just to give you a slight
nudge